ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้สวัสดีครับนักเรียนเย้
สวัสดีค่ะนัดอ้าวันนี้กลับมาเจอกับครัว
ตี้กับเครียมหาพี่กับนักเรียนนะครับใน
ช่องคอมเพรน Small ไทยเย้
ๆครับใช่แล้ว
วันนี้ที่เราเจอกันเป็นวันอะไรคะพี่
อาร์ตี้นี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้เราเจอกันวัน
นี้วันอังคาร
เรียนเขียนให้อ้าได้ครับอันนี้วันอังคาร
ขยายหน่อย
แม่
วันอังคารตัวเลขแบบอ้าวันอังคารใช่ไหม
ครับวันอังคารวันที่ค่ะนี้
วันนี้วันที่ 5 ค่ะอ่ะแม้ว่าวันที่ 5 วัน
อังคารไส้แห้งวันที่ 5 เดือนนี้เดือนอะไร
ครับ
เดือน
เมษายนค่ะทอดเดือนเมษายนเดือนเมษายนปีปีพ
ศ.หน่อยครับปีนี้
คศต.ค
2012  5  5 แคร์ 2022 แล้วปีคศนะครับข้อ
สองอะไร
ดีผช
[เพลง]
2565 ขอโอเควันนี้วันอังคารที่ 5 เดือน
เมษายนปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ 5 แล้วตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับ
เห็นตอนนี้
ตอนนี้บ่ายโมง 17 นาทีเทพบ่ายโมง 17 นาที
ที่ว้าวหน้าวันนี้เรามาเล่าเรื่องหนังกัน
ใช่ไหมครับใช่มามีนามีเรื่องอะไรจะมาเล่า
ให้นักเรียนฟังครับวันนี้
วันนี้เรียงไปดูหนังกับที่มันที่มันมีหมี
แพนด้า
หมอหน้าหมีแพนด้าอ่อนี่เรื่องนี้อ่ะขวดดิ
ตีเคยดูเคยดูเรื่องนี้ครับอย่า
ชื่อหนังอะไรคะเรื่องนี้ใช่ไหมครับถ้า
เพียงติดจำไม่ผิดนะถ้าจำไม่ผิดนะเรื่อง
นี้ชื่อกังฟูแพนด้า
ท่ากังฟูแพนด้าเป็นการต่อสู้กันต่อสู้กัน
ใช้ใช้วิชากังฟูหน้าใช่ครับ
เฮียเล่นกังฟูไปไหมอ่ะห๊ะ
เล่นกังฟูมาให้เป็น
เหมือนกันอ๋อหรือว่า
มันจะเป็นเรื่องราวของ
โปร
หอเป็นเรื่องราวเกี่ยวกับเกี่ยวกับโปร
เอ้ยโปรเป็นใครครับโปรเป็นใครเป็นด้าอ้อ
มีแพนด้ามีแพนด้ามีชื่อชื่อหมีแพนด้าตัว
นี้ชื่อว่าโปรใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะอ๋อ Honda ชั่วแล้วเขาก็ชอบชอบอะไร
กังฟูอ๋อโปรชอบเล่นกังฟูอ่าโอเค
แต่ว่าเขาก็ไม่เก่งหรอกกลางกูไม่เก่งอาหา
ครับยังไม่เก่งใช่ไหมตอนก่อนเอ่อตอนที่
เริ่มต้นเขายังไม่เก่งอ๋อใช่ค่ะแล้วที่
นี่ก็มีแล้วก็มีคนที่แบบเก่งกังฟูมากๆอ๋อ
อ๋อมีคนที่อยู่รอบๆตัวๆอ๋ออ๋อมิ.ยมี
เพื่อนอีกหลายๆคนเลยที่เก่งกังฟูแต่โปร
เนี่ยไม่เก่ง
ใช่มั้ยใช่อ๋ออ๋อเคก็เลยไปเรียนไปเรียน
กังฟูใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะที่จับได้ไหมครับว่าคนที่แบบกังฟู
เก่งๆที่อยู่รอบตัวโปรนี่มีอะไรกันบ้าง
อ่ามีเมียเมียเมียนี้จำได้ว่าคนที่เป็น
ครูเนี่ยคนที่เป็นครูที่เก่งที่สุดเลยที่
สอนสอนให้โปรเรียนกังฟูเนี่ยคือคนที่เป็น
เอ่อจิ้งจอกตัวเล็กนะครับชื่ออะไรนะครับ
ตัวที่จำชื่อไม่ได้และ
จ่ายทานที่ปู
ใช่ๆๆอาจารย์คนนี้เป็นคุณครูเป็นครูบางที
เราเรียกครูหรือเราเรียกอาจารย์ก็ได้
เหมือนกันเหมือนกันครูหรืออาจารย์เหมือน
กันอ่ะคนนี้เป็นอาจารย์ชิฟู 5 เป็นชื่อ
ของอาจารย์อาจารย์ชื่อว่าชิปู
ถ้า
ทำแล้วก็มีเสือก็มีเสือด้วยใช่ครับ
เหลือหน้ามีเสียดอ๋อ
กลับเสือชื่อไทย grape ขอ
เพียงตีจำได้ว่าเสือเนี่ยเป็นเสือผู้หญิง
ใช่ไหมครับเสือเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมใช่นะใช่
ไหมอ่าโอเค
แล้วก็มีใครหน้าไม่ใช่ครับนกอ้ามีนกนกก็
ดีเนียนหน้านี้เป็นนกกระเรียนโอเค
นกกระเรียนชื่อเครนอ๋ออ๋อว่าควรตี้จำจำ
ไม่ได้แถบชื่ออะไร Honor เรียนชื่อเคน
ก็จะไม่ได้นะเดี๋ยวก็อ่านเรียนเขียนเพื่อ
ให้อ่ะ
ฮะโอเคอมิสเหนือมีนกกระเรียนแล้วก็มี
อ๋อมีตรรกะแปะกดไปกับแฟนอยู่ตรงไหนออกจะ
แต่ว่าเล็กมากเลยพอตั๊กแตนตัวเล็กใช่อ๋อ
ใช่แล้วก็แตนก็เก่งกังฟูนะอ๋อก็ได้เก่ง
เหมือนกันว้าวอ่ะได้ค่ะแล้วก็แต่งชื่อ
แนนทิศอ๋ออ๋อแมนทิสใช่ไหมครับอ่ะโอเค
แล้วก็มี
งูอ้ามีงูด้วย
มีงูงู
ตัวสีเขียวอยู่ตรงนั้นโอเค
งูชื่อ viper
ออกฮะโอเคอ่ะ viper เอา viper เป็นชื่อ
ของงูนะครับชื่อหรอกเราจะพูดว่างูใช่ๆขอ
ให้เราจะเล่นขว้างงูเรียกว่าตะคัดแปลน
เรียกว่าเสือตัวสุดท้ายครับตัวสุดท้ายอีก
ตัวนึง
นี่ 5 หน้ากัน
จำไม่ได้แต่ตัวนี้เป็นลิงเป็นลิงนะครับ
อ่าใช่ค่ะโอเค
มังกี้อ้ามังกี้อ่าอันนี้จำง่ายทำง่ายๆ
ซื้อมันที่
ขายมันขี้ใช่ไหมเป็นมังกี้ขอ
หือ
ใช่อ้าเมียอาจารย์ชิฟู
ครับ
เมียจะหิวหมูแล้วก็มีคนหลายๆคนที่เก่ง
กังฟูอาหาร
โอเค
เดี๋ยวที่
ไม่เก่งกังฟูครับอ่าพึ่งมาเรียนพอเพิ่ง
มาเรียนก็เลยยังไม่เก่งต้องเรียนอีกเรียน
เยอะเยอะนักเรียนเยอะๆจะได้เก่งเยอะๆใช่
ค่ะเรียมดูเรื่องกังฟูแพนด้าเรียนก็ทำไม
ทำไมพ่อของโปรถึงเป็นเป็ดอ๋อโปก็มีพ่อ
ด้วยแต่แหกพ่อของโบเนี่ยโปรเป็นแพนด้าใช่
ไหมเหลี่ยมก็เลยสงสัยว่าไอ้เอ๊ทำไมโปร
เป็นแพนด้าทำไมพ่อไม่ได้เป็นแพนด้าข้อของ
โฟนีเป็นเป็ดใช่ไหมครับอ่าโอเค
ทำไมแพนด้ามีพ่อเป็นๆอ้ะอ้านั่นน่ะสิครับ
ทำไมอันด้านถึงมีพ่อเป็นเป็ดแล้วครับอ่ะ
น้องเรียมรู้ไหม
ค่ะๆที่ 1 ยังไม่รู้อ๋อ
หือ
จิ๊บเป็ดเนี้ยเขาก็จะขายขายบะหมี่อือมา
เฮ็ดขายบ่มีด้วยนะอ่าหายว่ามีโอเคขายว่า
มีเป็ดใหม่
ๆก็มีครับ
เราโปที่เป็นหมีแพนด้าเขาก็มาช่วยช่วยพ่อ
ของเขาขายบะหมี่
ช่วยคุณพ่อทำงานขายบะหมี่ขับใช่ค่ะเราก็
มีวันนึงที่ที่
ที่ชี้ฟูอาจารย์ชิฟูเราก็ก็อาจารย์
กูเขานึกว่าอาจารย์อ้าใช้ครับกูเคยนะ
กูกูกูที่เป็นเต่าใช่ไหมอันจาก
อาจารย์ของได้ชูก่า
ว้าวเรื่องนี้มีสัตว์เยอะแยะเลยนะมีสัตว์
ล่ะใครตัวเลยมีเต่าเต่าก็เป็นอาจารย์
ใช่อาจารย์
นี้ก็เป็นเต่าใช่ไหมคะที่อาจารย์ท่านเคย
อ่าอาจารย์เต่า a แล้วเขาก็บอกทุกคนว่า
จะหานักรบมังกรไงอ๋อจะหานักรบมังกร
กลับมาก่อนก็จะเก่งกังฟูม่าอ๋อ
ขับที่รู้จักมังกรมั้ยคะน่ารู้จักครับ
มังกรรู้จัก
ลืมหารูปให้ดู
มังกร
Earth
นี้มังกร are  Shinee มังกรครับขออาจารย์
อาจารย์เต่าต้องการจะหานักรบที่เป็น Mask
สอนให้เป็นนักรบมังกรใช่ไหมอยากจะฝึกใช่
เปิดนักเรียนให้เป็นนักองค์กรกังฟูให้
เก่งๆอ๋อขับ
หน้าแล้วเป็นยังไงเวลาคนอยากเป็นนักรบ
มังกรอยากเก่งกังฟู
เลยต้องมาหามาหาอาจารย์ที่ full มหา
อาจารย์พุงเคยที่โรงเรียนน้อ
ขึ้นบันไดมาหาเบียร์ที่เราจะมีบันได
บันได
ขึ้นบันไดไปบนบันไดที่อยู่บนภูเขาใช่ไหม
ครับขึ้นไปหาอาจารย์
ขึ้นไปหาอาจารย์เต่าอาจารย์อู่
จะขึ้นไปอีกอันกังฟูหน้าทำเราทุกคนก็วิ่ง
วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งขึ้นบันไดวิ่งแข่งพี่ไปไหม
ครับ
ถ้าวิ่งแข่งกันอยู่ไหนข้างบน
ใช่ค่ะเขาว่าถ้าเกิดวิ่งช้าๆๆก็จะไปถึง
โรงเรียนไม่ทันว่าเขาจะปิดประตูมือทำ
แล้วทุกๆคนก็เข้าไปในโรงเรียนเข้าไปในโรง
เรียนคันเวลาอ๋อเลยครับแต่ว่าเป็นโตเป็น
หมีแพนด้าที่ตัวอ้วนหาพี่อ๋อโปรวิ่งวิ่ง
ไม่ทันเหรอวิ่งวิ่งท้าวิ่งช้าอยู่ข้าง
หลังโน้นแต่คนอื่นคนอื่นเข้าไปหมดแล้วโปร
วิ่งช้าทำไมโปรวิ่งช้าครับทำไมโปรไม่วิ่ง
เร็วอะอ้วนค่ะเบียร์พี่หรอโพธิ์ตัวอ้วน
อยู่ไหนใช่มั้ยวิ่งช้า
โอเค 5 แล้วยังไงครับแล้วทีนี้อ่ะจะทำยัง
ไง
ทุกๆคนก็เข้าไปในโรงเรียนเรียบร้อยแล้ว
กล่าวว่า
โปรก็อยู่ข้างนอกก็เป็นหมีแพนด้าอ๋ออ๋อ
โบว์ยังไม่ได้เข้าไปอ่ะโทรมาช้าช้าวิ่ง
ช้าหรือ
ประตูประตูก็ปิดแล้วครับ
บอกก็เลยคิดคิดว่าจะเข้าไปในโรงเรียนยัง
ไงอ๋อ
เขาก็เลยเอาเอา
ตำรวจมามินิจรวดหรือเปล่า
ประทัดประทัด
ประทัดที่แบบออกไปจุดครับ
เขาก็ติดไว้ติดไว้ที่ตัวตัวของอูกเอามา
ปลูกในรอบได้ว่าใช่ไหมแล้วก็จุดไฟให้
ประทัดขึ้นไปอ้ะมาแล้วเป็นแล้วขึ้นเนี่ย
เราจะเอาไปได้ไหม
ขึ้นไปข้างในเข้าไปในโรงเรียนอ่ะอ๋อไม่
ได้เข้าทางประตูนะเอาประทัดถูกตัวแล้วก็
ลอยขึ้นไปบิลขึ้นไป
ได้แล้วอาจารย์พูห์เคยที่เป็นเต่านะคะถ้า
ครับเขากำลังอ่ะคิดคิดว่ากำลังจะเลือกนัก
รบมังกร
เขาก็เลยแบบชี้มือไป
แล้วโปรโปรก็ตกลงมาพอดี
ขอตกประมาตรงที่อาจารย์กำลังจะชี้ว่าใคร
จะได้เป็นนักรบมังกรน่ะอาจารย์กำลังชี้
ขอตกลงมาหัวหน้าหา
อาจารย์เคยก็ชี้ไปที่โป่งอ๋อพอดีเลยใช่
ไหมตอนนั้นพอดีเลยตอนที่โปตกลงมา
ใช่
ลดทุกๆคนก็ไม่เชื่อ
ไม่ใช่คิดว่าไม่ใช่นะดูอยู่โป๊ก็ตกลงมา
แล้วได้เป็นนักรบมังกร
คนก็เลยงงใช่เหรอใช่คนนี้เหรออย่างนี้ใช่
ไหมครับ
ใช่แล้วอาจารย์ที่ full อาจารย์ชิฟูก็เลย
ฝึกฝึกโป่งน้อหนักมากๆ
อาจารย์ชิฟูก็สอนให้โปรอ่า
โคเรียนกังฟูโอเค
ธรรมอาจารย์ที่ผู้สอนกังฟู
ทีเด็ดโปรเลียนกังฟูขับหน้าเรียนได้ไหมพบ
ปะเรียนกังฟูได้ไหม
ได้เลยนะเราค่ะไปนิดเดียวเองหรอ
ไม่เก่ง
เลยไม่
ว้าวเรียนไม่เก่งนะแต่ก็จะโปรไปอยากเป็น
นักรบมังกรเหมือนกันใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าอาจารย์ที่กูก็ไม่ไม่คิดว่า
โปรคือนักรบมังกรขอใช่โตไม่เก่ง
ว่าก็ต้องออกไปสู้
ออกไปสู้กับใครครับ
ออกไปสู้กับใกล้ลุงหมอไปลุงไปลุงเป็นใคร
ครับไปลุงเงินไปอ่ะ
แต่หนูก็คือนักเรียนนักเรียนของอาจารย์
ชิฟู
อยู่กับอาจารย์ที่กูมันก็เด็ก
ครับหนูไม่ถึงเสื่อใช่มั้ยใช่ไปลงไปเหลือ
ใช้ครับเป็นเสือที่เคยเรียนกับอาจารย์
ชิฟูแต่ว่าให้ลุงอยากเป็นนักรบมังกร
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าอาจารย์อาจารย์เต่าเนี่ย
อาจารย์อูเปนไม่สอนไม่สอนให้ใต้ลุง
ชายนี่คือตื่นให้ลูกเป็นเสือเพื่อนไหมอ่า
เหมือนแมวโอเคเป็นเสือหน้าด้านอาที่
อาจารย์เูควยไม่สอนไม่สอนใต้ลุงเนี่ย
เพราะว่าใต้ลุงเราเป็นคนไม่ดีช้าใช่แท็ก
เก่งเก่งกังฟูแต่เป็นคนไม่ดีเป็นคนไม่ดี
อาจารย์ใต้อาจจะหันผู้ป่วยก็เลยไม่สอนอ่ะ
มีแต่ไปลุงก็อยากอยากจะเป็นนักรบมังกร
เหมือนกัน
หรือให้ค่ะแล้วก็
ให้ลูกว่าถูกขังไว้นะคะสุขังไว้
แต่ว่า
ไปลุง
ไปลุงก็ออกมาอ๋ออ๋อมาข้างนอกได้นอกได้
ครับ
แล้วก็ออกมาทำอะไรครับ
หนูเขาก็มาหาคัมภีร์ไงคะเพื่อที่มอบขี่
มังกร
คำทีก็คือหนังสือใช่ไหมครับเป็นหนังสือ
ที่ข้างในหนังสือข้างในคัมภีร์เนี้ยจะสอน
วิชาวิชามังกรเอาไว้ใครที่ได้อ่านแล้วก็
ได้เรียนในหนังสืออีกทีมังกรก็จะเก่งนะ
ครับ
ใช่ค่ะอ๋อไปลุงก็เลยไปลุงก็เลยจะมาเอาคำ
พี่มังกรอันนี้
แต่ว่าโปร่งโปรได้คัมภีร์มังกรนี้ไปก่อน
แล้วนะอ๋อ
ห่าคัมภีร์มังกรไปแต่ว่า
เขาก็เอามาเปิดดูมันจะเป็นอย่างนี้ใช่ไหม
คะแล้วก็เปิดออกดูคำทีแล้วก็ไม่มีอะไรเลย
ค่ะอ้าวให้เข้าพี่มากรไม่มีอะไรเลยโปร
แล้วโปรทำยังไง
โทรก็หาไม่มีอะไรแล้วจะไปสู้สู้กับไอ้ลง
ได้ยังไงอ๋อ
หือว่าโพลคิดว่าในคัมภีร์มังกรจะต้องมี
แบบและลายอย่างให้โกเรียนรู้มีวิชาดีดีดี
ใช่ไหมมีวิชามังกร ddpro จะได้เรียนรู้
แต่โป๊เปิดเอาไว้เฮ้าไม่มีอะไรเลยอะไร
บอกก็เลยโตไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่นักรบมังกร
หือกระโปรงก็เลยกลับบ้านกลับบ้านไปหาพ่อ
หมอพ่อพ่อ
ของโปรที่เป็นเป็ดที่ทำบะมีค่ะใช่พ่อของ
โปรก็เลยบอกว่าความลับที่เก็บไว้ที่ทำ
บะหมี่หรือทำบะหมี่อร่อยมากๆอ๋อโอคือไม่
มีอะไรเลย
ครับ
เลยที่ทำบะหมี่ทำบะหมี่อร่อยมากๆอร่อยที่
บ้านไม่มีอะไรเลยแค่ใส่ใส่ไม่มีความรัก
อะไรเลย
ไม่มีขอไม่มีแคปข้อโปรคิดแล้วก็ใส่ใส่ใส่
ไหนแล้วก็อร่อย
ออกก็เลยคิด
[เพลง]
พกเก่งจังกูได้
ก็แค่
ก็แค่เล่นกังฟูหนอฝึกไปเรื่อยๆต้องคิด
อะไรใช่มั้ยอ๋อ
ให้
หือแป๊บโปรจะเป็น
ตัดเล่นกังฟูเก่งๆได้ถ้าโปรคิดว่าโปรเก่ง
ออกอ๋อ
ก็บอกมาดูคัมภีร์แล้วก็ไม่มีอะไรเพราะว่า
ทุกๆอย่างอยู่ที่เราอ๋ออยู่ที่เราจะคิด
ใช่อิฐที่เราคิด
ไม่ได้อยู่ที่ทำพีโอเค
ๆค่ะอ่านแล้วยังบอกไม่ได้ไปสอบใต้ลุงอาบ
น้ำแล้วที่นี้สู้กับไปลงแล้วสู้ได้ไหม
ครับสู้ได้มั้ยทีนี้
สู้ตอนแรกสู้ไม่ได้ครับเหอะกูไม่ได้
แล้วไปลงก็ได้คัมภีร์ไป
ได้รู้ก็เอาคำทีมาดูแล้วก็เปิด
ทำไมไม่มีอะไร
ให้ลุงก็งงเหมือนกันอะอ้าวทำไมไม่มีใช่
ไหมครับ
แต่ใต้ลูกไม่เข้าใจไม่รู้ไม่เข้าใจอ่ะคะ
แล้วก็มาสู้
อ้ายกับโออิทโกก็ชนะ 2 เพราะว่าโปรเข้าใจ
โอเข้าใจแล้วว่าอ้าว่าเอ่อมีอะไรอยู่ใน
คัมภีร์ที่ไม่มีอะไร
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ดิ๊กคิดเหมือนกันไหมตอนลืมตอนที่
เรียกดูแล้วก็หาคัมภีร์ไม่มีอะไร
แล้วทำยังไง
[เพลง]
เห้ยอ๋อเข้าใจแล้วว่าคัมภีร์คัมภีร์ไม่มี
อะไรเพราะว่าเราเป็นคนทำทำๆทำๆทั้งที่ 5
เราต้องเป็นคนคิดเอง
อาหาร
โว้โอโอ้ทีมชอบมากเลยค่ะกังฟูแพนด้าต่อ
อ๋อก็เลยโปรก็เลยชนะได้ลุงในที่สุดใช่ไหม
ครับอ่าไม่ใช่
อ๋อโปรก็เลยเป็นนักรบมังกรได้เป็นนักรบ
กวนคอนเป็นนักรบมังกรที่เอ่อไม่เก่งต่าง
ไม่เก่งกังฟูและก็เป็นนักรบมังกรได้เพราะ
ว่าเข้าใจแต่ว่า
ตอนที่ตอนที่หนังจบครับโอก็เก่งเรียนคิด
ว่าคิดว่าโปรเก่งกังฟูขอเริ่มเก่งขึ้น
แล้วอ่ะตอนจบใช่ไหม
ภาคที่ 1
ครับ
ว้าวดูแพนด้าเขาภาค 2 ภาค 3 อ๋อมีหลายภาค
ใช่ไหมแต่ภาคนี้คือคาดที่ 1 โอเคอ่าแล้ว
วันนี้ก็จบภาคที่ 1 ไปแล้วนะครับเรื่อง
กังฟูที่น่าภาคนี้เอาโปสู้กับไปลุงใช่ไหม
แล้วก็ชนะด้วยครับหน้าได้เป็นนักรบมังกร
น่ะ K  A อาเย้อาสระ
ครับถังถัดไปวีดีโอหน้านะคะก็จะมีการปลูก
ดาวภาค 2 ขอดูกันว่าโปรจะไปสู้กับไข่กับ
ใครอีกใช่ไหมครับโอเคเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ามาติด
ตามกันนะครับกังฟูแพนด้า 2 นะครับน้อง ka
วันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะนายหมดเวลาแล้ว
นะครับอ่าเดี๋ยวลาไปก่อนนับวันนี้แล้ว
กลับมาพบกันใหม่ครับกับจากครัวตี้กับน้อง
เรียมได้ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนซุปเปอร์ไทยนะ
ครับโอเคอ่ะสวัสดีครับทุกคนสิครับนัก
เรียนใหม่บายสวัสดีค่ะเฮียตี้สวัสดีจ้า
ครับบ๊ายบาย